start talking about it I believe it
happened and I'm sorry for the family
fairy god dammit stop saying I said it
happen mainstream you you grew it up by
taking that approach I didn't watch the
wars that killed millions of people
I didn't ship in the narcotics that
killed millions of people but how is it
I am the bad guy yellow do you
sensationalize yourself
I'm the globalist lethal injection and
I'm ready to die suck is watching right
now say Sandberg's watching Larry Page
Sergey would you ever want to be back on
these social media platforms or you're
okay if they never ever let you back on
again I just pray that God will have
mercy on my children so if you follow
the news if you follow media you're
gonna see this face you're gonna see
this name Alex Jones who is recognized I
think it's pretty fair to say you are
the most controversial political figure
in America today is that fair to say
something like that
yeah then uh why you is that I'm the
most banned person in the 21st century
there there's no doubt that I'm the most
demonized most attacked person in the
world today so you've been now banned
off what Facebook Twitter YouTube
overrated Instagram every single one of
these things over a hundred platforms
over a hundred platforms all have banned
you take our Apple app we just launched
a week before we got banned a month ago
it had over 2 million downloads so they
just banned it they went to number one
so we're banned for being number one and
then they want us banned so they can in
a lie about what I supposedly stand for
see that's what they do they ban you and
then they demonize you your YouTube
channel has roughly 1.5 billion views
give or take
that was just one up well that's just
one one they had 5 billion views total 5
billion views total they banned they
blew him all the way to over 20 channels
in one day just people now your website
you do what you do right now but what
are you doing right now what are you
thinking about all this stuff that's
taking place with you in the last you
know couple months your last six weeks
look I had a big audience and I'm on a
couple hundred radio stations still and
500 TV stations so we still resolve
people but Hillary Clinton ran ads about
a month before she lost in 2016 and she
thought it was such a negative figure
that they edited these tapes and they
they played these tapes out of context
demonizing me and that it connected
Trump
and then when she lost the Democrats
actually believed that I was Trump
spring
she ran 18 million dollars of ads the
Federal Election Commission says on TV
and the web saying that I am in charge
of Trump it's not true
here we're talking to Trump he's in
charge okay and I have something extra
to drop it like 1/10 of what they say so
they ran 18 million dollars of ads on
YouTube and Google and Facebook and TV
saying here's Alex Jones he's Trump
spring
he tells Trump what to do and I show a
clip of Trump saying something similar
and me saying something similar eighteen
million dollars eighteen million dollars
so they ran that who are the Federal
Election Commission and then when she
lost all hell broke loose we had like
advertising deals you name it I lost
like ten million dollars the first month
when Trump won everything was coming
after me they were the people are suing
me a man lost or gained you lost after
he won when he won they were after my
sponsors everything because they
actually believe their own propaganda
which wasn't true that I was like
telling Trump what to do and so once he
once he won they had run this ad
thinking connecting me out of context
with radical statements to the to to the
then candidate would demonize him but
then when it failed they believed their
own propaganda they smoked their own
dope and then almost two years later it
has been one hell of a ride they
literally believe their own BS that I am
in charge of Trump and I'm giving him
every move and it's the opposite I may
have talked to Trump's he's got elected
ten times and it's usually you know hey
Alex hope you're doing well god it's
where it's bad let's make America great
again let's unify people it's like Pat
me on the head phone calls I don't tell
Trump anything to do but the Democrats
literally believe because I'm
low-hanging fruit that if they get me
they've got Trump when's the last time
you spoke to Trump I don't want to get
into that but last few months last few
months and what's he telling you what's
he telling when you're talking to him
we're gonna turn the economy around it's
getting better we
to unify people we need to be positive
we need to bring everybody together no
matter what color they are who they are
it's literally like a pep rally you know
one of the things I'm curious about
where you're at right now if you are so
close to Trump if you've spoken to him
ten times ever since you've been banned
have you had a conversation with them
since the ban or no no I mean I've had
conversations with people high level in
the campaign and in the White House and
I've just said listen they've demonized
me as a strong man with 18 million
dollars during the campaign now it's
tens of thousands of articles a month
everywhere lying about me never showing
what I supposedly said just claiming I
said something and I said this is
clearly just like the Nazis did you pick
a group and then you demonize that
minority group and then once you've set
the pressure that people accept going
after them then it's everybody else so
I'm the first domino because I've
studied history I was learning to
understand that I'm not just supporting
they picked me because I'm flamboyant
and stuff out of context to demonize
Trump now that he won
they have ramped it up that I'm this
horrible person and then now they are
going to try to shut me down
and then once they shut me down over a
hundred plus platforms Facebook Twitter
Google iTunes you name it it'll be
everybody else and just like I predicted
as soon as I was shut down it was a
domino effect for everybody else so
that's the plan when he say domino
effect what do you mean by domino effect
who else like you're talking Praeger
you're talking other people are coming
after you what do you mean by domino
effect
you said it Prager University bans
shadow band blocked gap McGinnis you
name it I mean it's everybody has been
shadow banned or blocked my family will
I put a pro Trump tweet out or hey our
economy is doing great and they ban them
for a week on Twitter it's everyone I
know it's it's like Trump said the
tweets millions of people are being
blocked from the digital Commons and
people say oh these are private
you can't restrict them they are under
federal law as a digital Commons they
operate under the system and under the
rubric Det they are not publishers that
they are simply operating systems that
allow debate and so they have admitted
that they're a digital public square'
but what they're doing is selectively
banning nationalist conservatives
Patriots you name it from that digital
square fifty something days out from the
election has anybody ever been at the
level that you've been banned ever in
the history of America I know my law was
banned off Twitter but he was suspended
for like a couple of weeks it wasn't
like a permanent ban right I know Tommy
Lauren had an issue where a couple of
our YouTube channels were shut down even
I think PewDiePie had an issue right
with PewDiePie had an issue when he made
a comment about Isis and they were
uncomfortable with him so he lost his
verification but has anybody ever been
at the level that you've been banned no
no one pooty pie when it comes to
reaching young people has 21 billion
views on YouTube 67 million subscribers
last time I checked and they came to him
a few years ago and said play ball she's
her popular or we're gonna shut you down
he didn't so they began to claim he was
some political terrorist when he's done
nothing and that's exactly I'm talking
about I only have 5 million views on
YouTube he has 20-plus billion
he's number one in the world the late
shows all those combined are pooty-poo
but they came to him to muscle in and
say you better do what we want
politically or we'll shut you down he
didn't do that so they demonetized him
they've done all this to pudding pie and
he's been exposing what happened to me
but no no one has ever been banned in
over it's over a hundred platforms now
we have software companies calling and
saying you can't even use our software
they're looking at their own contracts
its tortious interference they are
literally engaging and trying to put me
in a digital gulag and again it's it's
because I'm exposing that our government
they sold out to multinationals I'm
exposing the Communist Chinese have
taken control of Hollywood ok control
the universities and have allied
themselves with radical Islam and all
the
to this that's why they want me shut
down and they believe that if they can
set the President to shut me down then
they can shut everybody else down so
that's why this is happening
don't you think a part of those comments
that you may get you in trouble
sometimes where you say things like
listen for myself right I'm politically
in the middle so I watched CNN F Fox
anytime anything happens because I want
to know what somebody's lying
one side is lying definitely right if
one side is and the other side is wrong
and one of them is making up some kind
of a story but every time I hear when
CNN or Fox when is whether it's Rachel
Maddow or Hannity or Tucker or Anderson
Cooper or Morning Joe doesn't matter
when somebody uses the word Nazi in
America and they say Hitler and all this
other stuff red flag goes up for me and
I'm a guy that's studying everything I'm
a guy that studies polity I'm a guy that
came from a family that's half communist
half imperialist born or raised in Iran
so when I see a comparison like that
made by people that have only lived in
America to me it's a red flag so how
much of this Alex do you think is its
self inflicted by you versus by the
media Tucker pushes hardcore Hannity
pushes or Riley pushed a lot of people
push but they're still out there why are
you the one that's being banned well
they call me a Nazi constantly even
though both my grandfather's almost died
in World War two it's it's it's they who
called you who's at them you would say
things I mean I mean any major names I
call you Nazi we've had like Tom Brokaw
say I'm an unalloyed racist okay but
that's not Nazi though well I mean I've
had was in DC last week will it run up
and scream you're a Nazi you're a Nazi
that's what they say that with specific
any major name because you do that all
the time and Bob well I want to say this
part to you that I think it's just fair
for everybody for both sides partially
why Braj my attorney said don't do this
and I and I spoke about that yes and as
my attorneys say Pat but I told you
that's our question no no I love that we
did I know you didn't and so when you
and I spoke I said look my attorneys are
concerned and so we went back and forth
but the reason see why should they be
concerned you've got your own because my
money's tied to them so they're coming
from a money what you say this yeah
you're a man has your own life
you say what you say I see what I say if
I was Jeffrey Dahmer who got interviewed
by the nose yep no one says why's the
moon why
n-b-c hear from Jeff Dahmer let's say
I'm worsted every dime fine I'm worse
Jeffrey Dahmer before he died last year
let's look let's say that Charlie Manson
you're allowed to interview Charlie
Manson now what is this new thing where
they say don't their interview Alex
Jones what is it because they've built a
strongman of things I haven't said I'm
glad for the tough questions they build
a straw man yeah and then they don't
want me to respond here's an example
there's a video on infowars.com right
now that only covered today because he
got national attention I walk out of the
sitting on the internet censorship and
these women run up is the Hispanic women
I love everybody this happened today
well know what happened last week but I
heard all day
got it and the news said that I called
them all these names no they said you're
a white piece of crap your family's
inbred you're a monkey all these things
I said you're a racist the national news
edited that with me saying you're racist
but not showing the clip of them saying
that you can have white racist Hispanic
races like black races whatever I'm
against all that I was Martin Luther
King so that's what I'm saying is is
that they don't they want to ban me so
they can then misrepresent what I've
said and what I've done but your whole
question going to is it self-inflicted
they're after me because they can track
back the reboot of 1776 they can track
back how the economy is coming back and
how the globalists suppressed things by
design to me and I know what do you want
the credit but they believe George Soros
the Global's believe that I'm the first
domino and that we triggered this
grassroots movement to launch Trump so
they believe if they take me out Trump
can continue on or be defeated so why
did I bring you on okay I'm a content
creator I'm a capitalist I'm an
entrepreneur when you're allowed to
interview who you was no but how far
down the ramp up are we that you've got
to even like ask can i interview alex
jones miss i could be adult hitler a
horrible person you have a right to
interview me so i so I interviewed
entrepreneurs on you know I mean
a minion entrepreneur channel we've had
Mark Cuban we've had Magic Johnson we've
had Kevin Hart but we've had Gloria
Allred I mean who has Gloria I had a
glory Audrey just to speak to to see why
it's great I've had this marker yeah
I've had Perez Hilton I've had Jerry
Springer Jerry and I went out of talking
about Hillary Clinton it was a friendly
debate that we had so I brought you
because there is partially a concern for
content creators when somebody is being
asked to you know don't say anything
this is going to some other countries
that ran it that way they told people to
not share their opinions even a Bill
Maher who doesn't agree with you a lot
of things that you say politically he
defended you Ted Cruz who I think
tweeted out and Ted Cruz said you know
here's a man who claimed my dad killed
the JFK like that's what he said on
Twitter you probably saw that he said
but you know there's this give the right
for these Facebook and everybody to shut
him down and take them up know so people
but I want to I want to preface this
question there are people who agree and
disagree with you who are defending you
the part I'm trying to ask from you is
to follow is there any part of this that
is self-inflicted that is cause I run a
business
we have flaws some of it is
self-inflicted some of us might see oh
oh some of us might see em Oh some of
it's my chief financial officer but I
know a lot of it is I should have done
better
what is cent self-inflicted from your
sight or saying yeah I'm gonna answer
that but let's go back since when in
America do we have to ask can you
interview somebody what have I said here
I love America I love free market I I
love making the country great what have
I said that's so damn evil because the
mainstream media projects what I've said
and done
and because they've created that straw
man they don't want me to be able to
respond but let me tell you if you go
back six years ago with Sandy Hook first
happened and my listeners called in it
didn't think it happened yeah and they
showed anomalies and so I had guests on
looking on both sides very small part in
my whole compendium you know the last 25
years it's less than 1% of what I've
done
less than 1% it's like 1/10 the percent
and so within a year or two I said no I
think Sandy Hook happened mass shootings
happened the media as soon as I said I
thought it happened because I'd
questioned it before went oh my god
we've got him and they went crazy and
then they just published thousands of
articles a week saying Jones is
harassing families he's going to their
houses he won't stop saying it didn't
happen and then I call him I sent him
letters and I'm like here's 50 videos
saying I believe Sandy Hook happened and
here's the debates where I just had open
discussions five years ago they won't
stop because it's like saying Saddam
killed babies and incubators in 1990
it's it's using that to demonize me so
I've already said I'm sorry the media
took it out of complex ten thousand
times I'm already said that I'm done all
that and they only like oh my god he's
weak on this and so it's in papers every
day Jones is harassing families Jones is
saying sandy who didn't happen
it's the papers saying that that are
saying that it's not me but but let's
expand on that I didn't lie about WMDs
in Iraq they killed over a million
Iraqis like the New York Times did no
one questions that so they're pulling on
the heartstrings not the families but
the lawyers and the Democratic Party
because they're scared of what I'm
generally saying that there's a
corporate world government taking
control of nation states like the Briggs
it and everything else and people are
waking up to that so they want to
demonize that and say you can't talk to
this guy because he's so evil and he's
so bad there was nothing in that answer
I'm asking the question was there
anything that you take responsibility
for where you say what for us in Sandy
Hook okay let's go with Sandy Hook
obviously that made a lot of families
feel uncomfortable the father Neal who
talks about my son was six years old he
got shot in the head and he held him in
his arm when he died and a couple other
parents that came out and said what they
said and make it Kelley asked me the
same question you've said some stuff you
know like maybe this will make sense for
what we're trying to do for me to
understand you because when I look at
somebody and I differ with their
political opinions I may not agree with
Barack Obama but I can see if Barack was
Barack and I didn't speak politics and
we had a drink and we spoke sports I'm
probably
get along with Bronk if I talk to
somebody like a bush and everybody was
talking werewolf ere was joking with him
all this other stuff if I talk sports
with Bush I'm probably gonna get
discussed seems like a nice cup gonna
have a good time together there are
sides of you that show sense of humor
there are sides of you that shows your
levity there are sides of you that shows
you you have a brilliant million mile an
hour brain that goes down what you talk
about it's a different story
sometimes in the world of sales and
maybe this will make sense on the
question I'm trying to ask sometimes in
the world of sales when I work with the
people in the world of sales there are
people who sell a product they'll come
on let you say the product is good
enough for me to give the features and
benefits here's what I'm selling Alex I
have a house 4-bedroom 3-bathroom corner
called the sack kids safety good private
schools etc etc and then I say but this
house underneath that there's a 63%
chance that there's oil and you can be a
billionaire do you everything do you go
from just selling the idea which already
makes a lot of sense you're making me
think then from there you going to let
me sensationalize and you get yourself
in trouble doing that do you ever feel
like you've done a worse kind of in
trouble oh I think there's no doubt that
I've covered internet sensations and
then the media says that I created that
sensation just because I cover the
sensation yellow do you sensationalize
yourself are you sensationalizing
yourself there's a big difference so I
can give a presentation and God knows
how many people have sold over the years
and I know what I sensationalized
sometimes have you yourself conscious of
saying [ __ ] to get maybe a sponsorship
maybe sell me you know to I know this
thing's gonna get 2 million views versus
220,000 views
let me sensationalize because in a
marketing aspect you know propagandas
work you know you know I'll be honest I
don't ever think sit there think I was
gonna be successful I go with what I
think is true and I've questioned public
events and I've done things like that
and well like I said you got mainstream
media that lied about Iraq and a lot
about the Arab Spring always tough and
they sit there like they're pure and
good here's my listeners question things
there's no question about that by the
way so so I want you there's no question
about that I don't trust either side I
don't watch the NE understand like in a
spectrum of 24 years on air like the
media tries to make me Sandy Hook that's
like 1/10 of one
of one point well let me give you the
credit on one thing that you do these
are credit it's not like you're 100% all
tried Republican no matter what you know
anybody on the right says you defend
that's not been your case you went
against bush and at a point when
Fahrenheit 9/11 came out you and Michael
Moore been on the same set which is
pretty weird thing to say that you and
Michael Moore well right I don't want to
put Michael Moore in jail like that Isis
is it was that's exactly right but
that's what I'm getting at is they
change the subject to expose a
surveillance state and world government
and globalism and they just the media
than brands at Sandy Hook Sandy Hook
Sandy Hook
I was not the first person to question
Sandy Hook other people did I know they
did I then looked at it and then I said
okay I think it happened and they want
oh my god he's weak let's go after him
and three four years later they're in
newspapers every day sewing Alex please
stop saying my son didn't dad I'm like
your son died he got killed please stop
saying I said it maybe because because
the whole Democratic machine and all
this is behind it so okay get rid of
America you're in a free market get rid
of the Second Amendment my god I'm sorry
Sandy Hook is everything just sacrifice
everything on that and if you're
involved in that socialism Venezuela
everything I'll jump off a cliff
I'm so sorry I don't think that's the
case but they act like they act like I
killed the kids of saying no I don't
think that's think there's a prozac head
with an illegal gun again and I think us
it's like one little thing I covered so
why don't you just come off ride this
with Sandy Hook here's very simple so
the kids died yes think so our use is
your argument on Sandy Hook which maybe
the viewers don't understand fully were
you trying to say I believe it did
happen but I believe the government had
something to do with it or this was
staged it never happened because those
are two different arguments to make if
you say this was staged by the
government well maybe that's a
conspiracy that we can say no I disagree
with let me explain let me explain there
have been real mass shootings before
sure and the kids were always into the
Nazism and when devil worship like
Harris and Klebold it
what happened in Columbine and it's
always the same story and a stay and
then they blame gun owners so then this
happens and the guys on Prozac
protect it he has a gun illegally and
then the internet says look at these
alumni you know all these anomalies
mm-hmm so I start looking at the
anomalies and I'm looking at them and
I'm saying is that true is this true so
we debate those and then about a year or
so after I start saying to people that
are saying I'm covering up because I'm
saying I thought it happened you yeah I
starts saying no I think it happened and
then it becomes this whole debate and
then reporters come to me and they say
tell us what you think really happened
what are the anomalies and then I say
the anomalies even though I've already
proven those anomalies aren't what they
say they were I'm saying I believe Santa
could happen here are the anomalies then
they sue me for saying what the
anomalies are cutting off that I say it
happened it's a way to like suck the
oxygen out of the room I literally one
tenth of a billionth of what I've done
is Sandy Hook and now it's constant
Sandy Hook exciting sandy just so you
know I got 15 more topics that up goes
nobodies ghost
the only question but you haven't
answered so I think it can simplify it
if you just say here's an argument are
you saying Sandy Hook was staged and the
people that walked that there were a no
I believe Sandy you know happened what
the government had something to do no I
believe Sandy Hook happened I believe
kids got killed at Sandy Hook and then
the public questioned it
I analyzed that and I apologized the
people taken out of context what I
questioned and then the media use it to
try to hurt families so I apologize for
the whole way it's worked so you're not
saying there's any government
involvement no I don't think okay so
that's but okay so that's great so going
back to the question again that I think
still hasn't been answered and this has
nothing to do with Sandy God like I said
9/11 you predicted 9/11 in July of 2001
and you said somes gonna happen we have
to be ready I said they're gonna blame
bin Laden blow up the World Trade Center
okay and would you say that was the
first time where people actually look
cause you've been on you've been on air
for 24 years it's not like this is a new
thing you're doing you've been doing
this for a while and you were whether it
was Austin whether it was whatever you
know your inspiration gave you that
being a dentist you had these types of
conversation you read political books
you're a guy that follows this kind of
stuff this didn't happen all of a sudden
one day you're like you are a believer
in where you talk
about this is an accidental but when you
talked about the 9/11 issue and you said
I think this is what's taking place and
I think the US government is
participating in this partially [ __ ]
whoever it is you were talking about do
you think that was the first time where
the audience and the media kind of was a
tipping point for them where they said
wow maybe he does have a point because
the Democrats were kind of saying you
know he's not even defending the guys on
the right side do you think that's one
media kind of favored you a little bit
you know one you know they were
demonizing me for that I just saw the
preparation for what was happening and I
and I knew about what happened
previously I had a lot of sources and so
again it doesn't mean that 9/11 wasn't a
real attack it means that certain
political interests stood down
I think it's 28 pages show that so I
just go with whatever I think the best
research is there are some content
creators that are worried to say well do
I need to also be careful because here's
a guy that maybe his voice is being
hidden you know maybe I need to be also
careful you know maybe I need to stop
talking about capitalism maybe I need to
start talking about some of this stuff
what is your concern now that you don't
have access to social media today how
are you feeling how does it feel like
knowing you can log on to YouTube
Twitter create any content what's life
like without social media it's great
because it's gotten me to realize what I
already knew that
we're already shadow band we were
already being controlled we were already
being dialed back we're already giving
our soul this fraudulent thing and so we
need to build things outside of that to
really create a free society and so we
have more real viewers more real
listeners more dialed in people than
we've ever had under the sensor show
today yeah so what happened the moment
you got band's interview I know your
website is ranked 6 I think 6 23 in US
alone and I think worldwide your 2869 if
you look at the rank you know well
exercise of today what's happened to
traffic from the day you were been and
what's have seen to see Alexis run by
Amazon three years ago more than 5,000
conservative sites or delist at 80
percent one day and his father's column
said my god we're still getting response
but you're down 80 percent I'm like look
at the graph it goes straight down
yeah we have record sales so going into
the campaign three years ago Amazon
totally delisted everybody and did that
just to try to hurt our sponsors but our
sponsors went well we're getting regular
response hour traffic's way up so here's
what happened and three years ago
Alexa's going like this it's Amazon and
then it goes like this and it goes like
this because our tribe it was really
going like this but they just went like
this so that's the same crap they keep
pulling that's why it's like but how do
you feel about not being on social media
right now you okay not be not ever being
on again are you okay with that if you
never ever ever are allowed back for the
rest you later and already well no it's
horrible to take somebody's digital
identity yeah like the common Chinese
have done and create a web ID for you
and they create a global social score
and use your views to intimidate you and
show you now that's what Communist China
has done
it's horrible authoritarianism but I'm
not the average person it's going to
criticize the system and then be banned
I've got hundreds of radio stations TV
stations but for the average person it's
absolutely horrible it is it is the mark
of the beast it is dehumanizing people
is it slaving them it is a terrible
situation but I'm speaking about you how
are you feeling about it right now
here's Alex's so it's kind of for me
when I look at somebody like you I lost
my voice for 90 days four years ago okay
and if you're running a business and you
selling you speaking all the time I mean
yeah that's not good Paula Park they
thought it was a cancer I had to go it
was benign they did a surgery I lost my
voice Thanksgiving I couldn't talk for
90 days voice was gone
jeez I couldn't speak at all and so for
me it was a way for me to sit back and
realize you know the smallest little
thing is a big part of your life so I
felt like if I can't speak lies right
fraggle right if I can't speak what do I
do so today if five billion views are
gone
how is Alex Jones feeling today and
that's five billion views just on
YouTube not including everything else
just 16 million iTunes subscribers all
I feel good because I'm gonna sell out
and I'm a trailblazer and people project
Who I am they lie about me all day but
we've never had more hardcore listeners
and I'm just I just believe humanity I'm
petting on humanity and they they they
build these from in of what I've said
and what I've done try to sell the
public on that and then they think if he
can demonize Alex Jones we can demonize
everybody else and then once they accept
destroying him did they like SEP
destroying everybody else so they're
trying to actually believe that that
they've did they're doing him so so but
let's let's focus on you how are you
feeling today I can tell you I didn't
like the fact that I couldn't speak for
three months right I interviewed Richard
turned a car mechanic and he said one
day he looks at he can't see anything
but he says life changed for me that's
like suddenly your voice has gone for
social media social media today's a
bigger platform than radio I think you
said one time to Rogen where you said a
lot of these guys on CNN and Fox maybe
have a hundred thousand listeners maybe
you have a million listeners Joe you
have millions of listeners
I have billions of lit you're saying
these stats that you're given to people
you don't have it today how are you
feeling and are you okay if you know
here's get it back here's the difference
if CNN or MSNBC was covering real topics
they'd have the audience any forum this
popular any forum that has something
great going on is they have the audience
so you're saying how am I feeling today
I'm not trying to be positive on this
because I'm worried about censorship and
Amazon banning books everything else
going on but we we have the biggest
audience we've ever had so you're okay
if they never get there if you've been
permanently there's never ever no one's
ever gonna let you back on this one
website called Facebook with two billion
views right now here's the thing are you
okay if you never ever allow what
they're doing to everybody as wrong as
election meddling and the censorship and
its corporate racketeering yeah but I'm
saying I'm at the top of the food chain
so typically talking don't know what I'm
saying I'm it yeah I'm not worried about
me but I'm at the top of the food chain
so technically I have more hardcore
listeners and traveled in for
calm and more people supporting us and
more radio stations and TV stations let
me tell you something you think being on
Facebook or Twitter with all their game
crap is big when you're on 50,000 watt
AM stations a hundred thousand watt
stations in LA in New York they still
have giant audience Alex I'd get that
but we both know the guy that became
president it's because he understands
Twitter you know that I know that I mean
he figures out that the Internet's key
no no I'm not saying that Internet is
the future yeah I'm simply saying that
they are attempting to shut everybody
down now and they're engaged in
classical authoritarianism against free
speech and so they they they they build
me up as a straw man they demonize me so
that no one stands up for me when they
take my speech and that is the key to
shutting everyone down I get it okay so
let's just say duck is watching right
now say Sandberg's watching Larry Page
Sergey you know you'd folks at YouTube
they are owned by Google doors all these
guys are watching right now would you
ever want to be you know figuring out a
way to be letting you know be back on
these social media platforms or you're
okay if they never ever let you back on
again are you okay with that never again
I'm Alex I'm Alex Jones I'm never
changing whether you take me back or not
I am never changing the single way I do
anything I don't care if I'm ever back
on it is that where you're at today well
obviously they're like 90% of the
internet obviously I want back on that
okay but they misrepresent everything
I've said and done it's like Jack Dorsey
went on a month ago on NBC CNN ABC all
of it he went on with Lester holding
those roles like Joan says he wants to
kill the media with assault rifles
endorsed he goes Jack Dorsey those I
know it's horrible but he can stay I
never said that
so but go see the first time he defended
you to do that was all like acting like
he was I talked to folks over in the
meeting with him when I confronted Marco
Rubio who walked up to the press
conference Jack Dorsey said oh my god
now he's been mean to Republicans he's
not done they are now I can ban him who
told you though you assuming that or who
knows people know he wasn't meeting
people in the meeting telling you that
now that you're going after Marco Rubio
this is an opportunity for Dorsey to ban
talk to folks that were in the meeting
with checked Dorsey okay
and he goes oh I can ban Alex Jones down
I just wanted for a Republican that's
how dumb they are I mean it's a total
joke
do you think dorsey's a Trump fan no
okay we both know that he's not how come
he hasn't been Trump he's more powerful
than you are there's there's a reason
why how come Trump's now because it's
way obvious he's already one of the
worst banners out there and so by
leaving Trump up there Trump could
announce some new service or some group
overnight and destroy Twitter in one
minute yeah but the point I'm trying to
make to you is I don't think Dorsey I
actually think Dorsey defended you and
by the way I am NOT on Dorsey said
politically I actually that's not no he
did it for he only did it for cover but
you and I both know if let's just say he
isn't he's helping out Hillary Clinton
for 80% of media is on Clinton spite
side hypothetically you know that I know
that a lot of Belen sites have since 80
let's just say 80% is right you take a
bribe bard let's just say you take out
Drudge Report Fox News and you take some
of these things that New York Times
Washington Times that you say they're on
the right 80 percents on the left but
how come Dorsey hasn't done something to
Trump he could easily do it what if he
does so big of a move but he could have
done that pre election time so I I think
there is something that happened to TV I
wish I hope Jack Dorsey takes Trump off
Twitter that will blow up in his face
pecked know he knows he was scared to
even take me off and then when I got in
Rubio's face he literally said oh god
that's our cover get rid of it so you
think the tipping point will
Rubio oh I know people are on the
meaning why would Rubio be a tipping
point you confronted somebody he
disagrees with no no no you think he's
under the wheels I thought it was no he
thought it was bipartisan he thought oh
look he's mad at Republicans that's how
dumb they are I get it he's a big tech
head and all this stuff now knows Ranko
do you remember back in the days when
Beck used to be the main guy to watch on
Fox him and O'Reilly would go at it and
he was coming up and he would get up and
he would do a show then I was on Beck
one time and he would show this outside
you know yeah it was like yeah yeah and
Hitler did this and you know and
everybody's oh my gosh this could be a
conspiracy and it's tight you know and
even rush but these guys haven't been
banned off Twitter these guys haven't
been banned off YouTube you've been bad
so what is that part of it because well
let me read something let me just watch
it why do you think it is why sure as
hell is it because they say I question
Sandy hug no I don't think that's the
only thing no it's because I cover the
geopolitical system and how they're
setting up a world government and how
they want eugenics and depopulation and
how the Communist Chinese have merged
with our big tech companies to take over
the US that's why and you believe that a
hundred percent I don't believe it I
know it so how come the rest of the guys
are not off why is Beck not off Beck is
uh Beck is not a guy that they agree
with wise a Limbaugh not off why is Milo
still back on and Milo may be one of the
most annoying social media discos band
on Twitter let me ask this what I'm
trying to tell you there's where guy why
do you think I'm bad I think I think
it's over selling for instance you say
well the water they haven't like I don't
when I was in the Army and they would
say with the punch they put in the army
that you drink it it's purposely set up
so you don't get too excited to want to
have sex because when you're in boot
camp and AIT you know they don't want
you to be too sexual because you're not
gonna feed them CC opposition so they
got to tame you down a little bit now
that was a rumor that we're saying that
we'd say okay maybe right maybe not
right but I think you'll take that and
you'll say something like well you know
it's because you know Clinton is tied to
not
see in Hitler and then you sell it even
bigger here's what you did what happens
when I have 500 Harvard reports guy
about atrazine causing low sperm counts
then I cover it then that's the big
secret it's not I think punch I don't go
oh my god punch yeah it's my turn to run
and you say the water they're feeding us
as the water that they put into you know
frogs and not frogs are becoming gay
because they want our kids to be gay I
mean what do you mean frogs are becoming
gay well that's actually Bertrand
Russell in the UN they said we will add
chemicals to the water to confuse the
sexuality or this population that's
official UNESCO plan have you read the
book naked communist like Leland Skousen
you know which one I'm talking about
I've read the I've rather naked
communists mmm read the naked capitalist
he wrote okay yeah I know I've seen
these these methods on what they want to
do to take away the original oh here's
the sperm count the general sperm counts
out about 90% in the West
yeah but the frogs what's the story with
frogs being gay with the water they dog
do you watch frog porn how do you wanna
look oh you know how a huge fan of front
no no it's funny you say that like I
love frog porn talking about this frog
porn you're talking about here frogs are
amphibians so they're in the major water
dump of systems and like 10 years ago
they had a show on democracy now okay
and they had one on PBS okay and I
played the reports how most the frogs
were asexual or we're trying to have sex
with other males and so frog populations
were going down 90 percent and I talked
about it the media attacked me and said
Jones is homophobic against gay frogs
somebody the joke I said oh my god
they're putting stuff in the water to
make the friggin frogs gay and they took
that out anybody can search a democracy
now anybody can search PBS and so it
becomes this debate about Alex Jones
instead of the runoff is so toxic that
our kids are involved in the
emasculation of men and the it causes
women breast cancer you know all it
really hurts people that it becomes this
big thing and I just sit there
just go okay I mean I'm the biggest
version terrorist I I covered PBS
Democracy Now right about their headline
Democracy Now was run off making frogs
gay so I was reading a Democracy Now
headline and ten years later no one
shows that remember to clip when you did
it you just said you know the returning
get you you were just speaking you you
were well I just played the clip yeah
and I said oh my god they're making the
friggin frogs game I mean why would you
say something like that they're making
slugs so the chemicals aren't bad it's
it's me saying no let's no let's just
say the chemicals are bad that's what
I'm trying to tell you so okay for
instance you say something like this you
say I'm telling you folks nerds are one
of the most dangerous groups in this
country because they end up running
things but they still hate everybody
because they weren't the jocks in high
school so they play little dirty games
on everybody they use their brains to
hurt people and I'm aware of them okay I
see you little rats okay you say
something like that so I sit there and I
say interesting fair enough that's
actually not a bad point I remember the
guy that was a nerd 4.3 GPA he didn't
have any girls I wanted to get with them
so he probably didn't get late till he
was 22 so he says I'm gonna go out there
become so successful because this not at
that point fair okay I'll take that
right but then you'll take that and you
go Bill Gates is trying to do what he's
doing in Africa and he's trying to do do
this and you know he's not really
somebody that's making anything you'll
take it even deeper and so I sit there
and I say okay let me go research Bill
Gates maybe he's got a point here so
I'll go and do research hypothetically
somebody that's a reader somebody that
likes to research somebody that's not a
naive u're that's just gonna jump to
conclusion then I say come on Alex your
sensational eyes they're like come on oh
my god Bill Gates his dad headed up the
army program on eugenics and was the
head of Planned Parenthood and he went
on Bill Maher and said we need to reduce
world population I got all the clips man
yeah but Alex you take it to a point
where the media sitting there saying a
guy okay
a naive mind can here to some listen to
somebody like you and you can really
mess with a knife mind
in naive mind who is not gonna hear me
do you know about cold freaks Harbor
tell me about it I mean Bill Gates his
dad ran it okay
IBM runs it now sure so that is the main
human genome eugenics center the whole
deal it they trained the Nazis they
trained the the the Kaiser Wilhelm
Institute
there's Pulitzer prize-winning books
they have it all Mountain Alex what is
it you keep asking why are they after me
no because I read the books I've got
their plan Alex if you know everything
that you say you know and you got their
plants why are you still alive well
they're murdering my name they're
assessing me yeah well you've said
Hillary Clinton's you know her clan goes
and you know all these people I get
close to her so if you're opposing the
most powerful Democrat in the
marketplace that you say because they
thought I was a joke like a poison I
titrated it I and it's like God worked
it wasn't me we built up they thought it
was a joke they uses against Trump
they kept thinking they were winning and
now when the poison the truth is so
strong when the big dose hits them they
already I'm figured out and so I'm just
oh they're on the globalist lethal
injection and I'm ready to die so let's
just be clear I've already won this is
all gravy from this point on so they
already in the system I've already won
and they thought it was a joke and now
they just took their death does really
I'm gonna kill the New World Order
that's what they called me violent well
they hate me I'm not physically her name
buddy but the information is the end
it's there in two days
you think so no one can reverse it now
yeah I know it's true because humanity
wants to live and they're the ones doing
this I studied their papers
I studied their program and you asked
why they're so afraid they're so afraid
because I've got their number and I'm
not afraid to die so that's it
ask you sir questions so if that's where
you're at
who cares if you ever get back on social
media I don't you really don't the
message the transmission everything else
now is gravy everything else is just
getting ready to meet God when he a real
man I got to take my licks I'm ready
everything else does take my licks is
that why my kids got to take the licks
my family's got to take the licks I
gotta take the licks I'm ready take the
legs so let's get it going here
some of you the God forever doesn't
matter anymore I'm taking my licks see
that's how God works it's not just a
system where everybody's a coward and
sells out now there's people that aren't
cowards there's people that are
dedicated the truth and a rating all the
way and not just put themselves in the
line but their whole families so you got
three kids now looks at four you got
four kids yeah I thought you had 10 to
15 year-old right 10 to 10 or 15
year-old I got a 16 month old Robin to
the 16 year old 16 month old up right up
to a 16 there's no this exterminates
anti-human and if I don't do this they
have no future anyways and that's the
liberating understanding is that if I
don't commit to the truth and take this
they have no future there's a very
narrow window we've got for humanity so
what's next for you I mean what's it's
all about humanity's choices I'm not
even important anymore I've already
completed my mission long after that
they figured out what we did to him they
came after me I already did the job what
what ever happened to you right now you
don't think any of it is self-inflicted
none of us are perfect
I've done a lot of mistakes if I went
back in hindsight on a lot of things
different but the media miss rivers is
what I say so how can I say sorry for
things they said so you are just not
even letting them have one on you you're
not giving him one bone oh I've said 500
times that I believe Sandy Hook habit of
going back for years they never said it
so you're like let them
have one on you yeah but I mean you get
banner you come out and you're going in
front of door see you were at his court
you know you were chasing him down
you're chasing Rubio down I mean you're
you know he is is a no no no when they
told me lay down and die banging
completely I'm fight back absolutely
I want fire wait you've seen nothing
yeah I've seen nothing so this whole
thing with pizza gate theory none of
this stuff that you have they welcomed
Affleck Church running giant pedophile
rings that's confirmed and the fact that
was in the WikiLeaks that there were
these giant child kidnapping rings NBC
ABC CNN they focused on a pizza place in
DC to divert everyone like a broken you
like it mom bird the mother actually
gets wings broken so we had it all like
the kids are going to be in the hot tub
and Obama wants the hot dogs $65,000
worth we were covering them and then
they diverted off to DC and people
covered it and I said oh yeah that's not
what was going on so they go oh my god
pedophilia doesn't exist well I know
pedophilia exists it's all coming out in
the news and your old PR telling me
isn't gonna work so again we go back to
Sandy up six years ago kids getting shot
by a prozac head who's got a gunny
lately and I've been saying for years I
think it happened but the media keeps
saying I didn't and we go back to pizza
gate pedophilia doesn't exist well
everybody knows it does so again I'm
just I'm far beyond even caring what
people think anymore I've genuinely
tried to cover the facts I've genuinely
looked at things I've been set up I've
been led down rabbit trails that part
doesn't matter
the truth is this world governments
coming down this whole vampiric system
it's coming down I felt damn good about
it it's comments like that they get you
in trouble what you just said right
there this whole government is coming
down this whole corrupt system is coming
them define corrupt system ran by who
the private interest the Federal Reserve
the big Vatican systems the traffic and
children the people that ship narcotics
into America
the corrupt system is in the spawn
line and it's coming down and to make
this clear you're not talking about one
side of politics you're saying this has
happened on both sides you're talking
about the elitist and what I'm saying is
is that I'm dead already
I already passed the River Styx so
everything I'm doing now is pure victory
see this is the kamikaze mission people
think humanity just takes this stuff no
the spirit of humanity manifests itself
in resistance and so that's what's
happened it's not about it's not about
me it's about what do we do to Hollywood
what do we do the corrupt blueblood
Republicans what do we do the Democrats
what do we do to let them know we're
still alive and that's what I've done it
doesn't mean you know that things don't
get a little messy in this thing at the
end of the day I'm not raping little
kids define messy I didn't watch the
wars that killed millions of people
I didn't ship in the narcotics that
killed millions of people but how is it
I am the bad guy I'm the guy you can't
talk to I'm the guy that can't be heard
I'm the guy that's gotta be banned
there's got to be reason for it though
well it's because the mainstream media
are good people
I mean Apple and Google and Facebook are
nice people and they're protecting you
from Alex Jones that's why these are
good people
these are sweetie-pies mark zuckerberg
he called his users dumb [ __ ] but he
didn't mean that
he's a angel he's a sweetie pie and so
is Nancy Pelosi and so is Michael Moore
they're not bad people they're good
people and we should just world over
because you saw what happened Alex Jones
you saw what happened to him so you
better sit down and shut up and you
better do whatever we say or you're
gonna pay let's see
some people don't care some people don't
care who some people know the people
that are awakening the people that are
about to bring this corrupt world down
and build a new world up who's got your
back right now outside of the people
that follow you're like whoo-hoo-hoo
that has a name it's fighting for you
right now that's why I asked when's the
last time you spoke to Trump if he
reached out to you and said I'm gonna
help you because I know when you won he
went on Infowars and then he say
something like Alex I'm gonna make you
proud or when we get in somehow Sarah
Saracen Trump called me after he wanted
said thank you
I'm I'm giving my energy to trump I
don't need him to protect me he's the
maze the lion in the under attack by the
aim is sure he doesn't I don't call
Trump for support Trump knows he's got
my full support you asked them for help
publicly got some for help just recently
no I've asked him to defeat the enemy
trying to shut down for his page there's
a big difference isn't that in a way
indirectly asking for help or no no no
he understands he has to take action
against the tech giants that are
chukkamma funded trying to dominate us
that that's for all well you know he's
already not on the side of Bezos he's
not a fan of Bezos on what he's doing
but yeah Bezos and them are Bezos and
Amazon have their own problems but
they're their child's play compared to
Google and Apple because of influence
obviously Amazon's game is a different
game then they're here in America right
and so Amazon's are least for our
problems got your back till right now
who's backing you up right now who's
calling me saying hey I'm gonna go out
there and fight for you
the strongest thing you can do is to
have nobody having your back I mean it's
like no it's like the Alamo you know
about 1836 sure 180 people fighting like
5,000 everybody dies but they knew that
was gonna happen they were so pissed off
that when Travis drove the line the sand
almost everybody stood across it so see
these are real sacrifices these aren't
like Satanist sacrifices or they do a
little kid and all these people from
that powerful it's about giving yourself
very christ-like so it'll be remember
Infowars you remember Alex Jones when we
win this and watch the next phase of
human expansion you think what you don't
read no it's christ-like yes I think
standing up for what's right being
and building a future was in the spirit
of Christ I would say it's Christ's life
he had allies right I mean even his
Judas let you say you backstab them but
Jesus had a lot of allies huh no I've
added a 12 oh you don't think people
back them up
Luke mark Matt you don't think so I'm
asking who's on your side right now but
yeah that's what I'm telling you is that
we've already changed the world and I
need to take my licks and I will take
them fine you're taking it right now but
who's got who's in your corner today
Alex this is five billion views you have
been heard your website gets tens of
millions of traffic that come in you're
not you're not a blogger that got
excited and made a rumor about a video
with Kim Kardashian and they post it
available actually a question again yeah
why does the system fair what we do they
don't care about kids at Sandy Hook they
don't care about Iraq they know why is
it because it's the spirit but who's got
your back right now that the spirit does
outside of the Spirit who has there is
nothing but the spirit in the political
side left right middle business who is
saying I'm gonna spend money to go out
there and make sure alex is back on a
platform I'm gonna make sure I've got
anybody
I'm not directed by any group but I will
tell you that Patriots and the Pentagon
and the military are watching Google and
Facebook of these arrogant [ __ ] very
closely and I'm not coordinating anybody
but I can tell you that I think when
they make their moves they'll be
unpleasantly surprised by what happens
and I feel really sorry for them and
that's just what happens to happen to
these people has anybody gone vocal
saying I'm gonna back you up I'm not
talking Mar Ted or Rubio I mean you go
to Ruby on Rubio says who is this guy
don't know this guy you know Marco Rubio
song no but what I'm trying to say so
about me Matt Drudge is that a lot of
courage okay
one of the biggest websites in the world
yep George poor commie he's backed me up
and it's not about me being backed up
it's not like I said there go I'm gonna
do the right thing am i backed up here
I've exposed the human-animal chimeras
I've exposed the surveillance here the
smartphone's I expose the world
government that's unelected I
rebooted with my listeners the entire
resistance worldwide and that's why they
hate me because they track it back to
Brazil they track it back to rocky avec
Iceland they track it back to Eastern
Europe they know that Infowars was
ground zero and like I said that was
years ago
I've already metaphysically know that
I've got an important work to do as long
as God wants me to but I've already
moved on and it the world's moved on
it's not about me and my temporal power
on this planet I'm a dead man and like
everybody else and I'm just moving
forward and sea lion hasn't eventually
gonna die or dead man meaning your
couriers you're done Wood has did
neither the enemy wants me dead
and I'm comfortable that so that's it
I'm dead and I'm ready so the work is
already done you figure it out like I
blew the blahblah stop it's already
happened how you doing emotionally right
now I love it yeah you get very close to
God very close to God baseless you know
effect I always felt my heart stomach
knots my bones like like every moment is
like close to God I can't explain it I'm
so close to God right now I am are you
in prayer mode right now you are you
speaking all the time I feel good so you
rely on the piece I am it now I'm now at
peace I'm now at peace it's not my name
or Who I am the enemy knows I love God I
love Jesus and so I've already passed on
and that's why the enemy hates me
because I'm well beyond the grass mill
far beyond that rest I just pray that
God allowed mercy on my children but I
trust God
so it's God's will now
so you don't think there's anything here
for you to figure out a way to bring you
back and have this be a second coming of
Alex's mind getting to work and doing
all that stuff you think it's it for you
right now
Oh I mean Lord works in mysterious ways
I'm just telling you that I knew what
trouble is elected election night did I
told her but I said it seemed to get
really bad they're coming after it's
like we've won it me the president we're
all set I said no I said no we're not
set get ready and I said I've completed
my work and everything else now is up to
everybody else so I've already completed
the mission
and Trump's trying to complete the
mission and now Trump is giving us
prosperity and everything else and if we
don't take it then that's us see it's a
spiritual choice and so I'm not worried
about me I really am NOT people think oh
you're being a tag being a lot about
like because we're on target we know the
program and we know it better than the
Satanist and because we know the program
they hate us because they don't have the
next level understanding so I'm not
worried I mean there's all these
questions about GMO and vaccines and
globalism and the fertility dropping and
the families and little kids committing
suicide everywhere just evil it's
flooding in and it becomes this thing
about Alex Jones question standing up
he's a bad guy oh my god
you know when they staged all this other
stuff before anybody would question that
babies and incubators you know about
Iraq the babies the incubators 1990 and
so it's the other day I'm just not
worried like I don't care about the
world I don't care what they say up
honey I don't care or you think still
staying up to date are you still
following the news are you still
following what's going on are you still
reading are you still waking up and
going through the same live sure here's
the thing
I'm sure if I got some great new future
and taken turn around they're great it's
just I know metaphysically like a b-17
over Nazi Germany I already dropped
bombs it blew up their power plant and
I'm flying off and they're on like the
measure Spencer
chasing me but I can look back and see
the power plants on fire like the
mission was complete I hope I go back in
land and get back in and go and do it
again
but I already blew them to high heaven
you're not saying I've done my job has
been served you know I'm not gonna go
out and play in offensive anymore you're
saying you're still doubling down
playing offense you're not that I'm
already fundamentally like a Super Bowl
team wins like three or four Super Bowls
okay I got one other Super Bowl it's not
about a person I'm gonna yeah of course
but they're no more the America the
words of wait brother they're awake to
globalism it's over get the chain
reaction from Brazil to Russia to the UK
to Germany to everywhere it's already
happened and so it matters how hard the
road is for everybody we love the
children we hope they don't go through
pain but we've showed the children the
way I'm telling you is the fuse is
already lit the information already
detonated and so I hope I can help
people in the future but I've already
the enemy already metaphysically knows
that I with God's help it's all God and
all Jesus already devastated them I
foresaw it when I was a teenager in long
before I repaired it and I built it with
everybody else's energy we were all
together but I was at the front of the
line we did that with Christ's spirit we
defeated the enemy now the enemy's
coming on to me and that's good because
while I'm doing this our people are
already light years ahead
and while I delay them here we're
winning understand that while I delay
them here while they chew me up and
destroy me our children are launching
into the next level
what's your older son saying about this
whole thing he knows he blows everything
he loves he's awake has he been banned
can he stood like this you still have
accounts Kinney still owes I hasn't only
been only I felt my shell feet on time
so they haven't gone after your kids yet
it's mainly with you right now yeah but
what's this idea that Facebook and
Twitter and Google or everything they're
everything because we say the
or like Matt Drudge said we have to
build our own thing well you said this
you've said it yourself though you sit
it on Rogen where you say oh no they
have the monopoly sure we handled today
well King George had the monopoly 2 or
40 years ago let me ask you a different
question than here is there a concern
that all of a sudden a GoDaddy can say
we're not hosting Alex Jones , what's
the next they're already trying the
Washington Post take our payment
processors shut the websites down I mean
I I'm gonna fight all the way to the end
as hard as I can but if they take that
stuff away from me it's not like oh my
god I'm out on air which means they can
finally take a break so you're fine if
you're off site you are completely done
whatever no I'm not fine with it it's
tyranny well then let me ask you this
I'm ready if they put a gun to my head
yeah and so three of your 7 Magnum is
safe you denounce Jesus Christ and
America and freedom are gonna blow your
head off I'll say pull that goddamn
trigger so I'm beyond them it doesn't
matter what you want you have I know
their plan but you have no desire to go
and go back and try to rekindle the
relationship and ask for hey what do I
need to do to get back nothing like
that's on your mind at all I love how
all the headlines are Jones banned for
life like it's an execution they want
this is a worldwide internet ID a
worldwide social score to train us to
submit to evil and watch what we say so
or they'll ban us and then they
misrepresent what we said no it's pure
evil I'm not worried about that
Jesus that's what I'm getting in is that
why don't we talk about these big
corporations selling deadly drugs why
don't we talk about these big
corporations selling evil talked about
that talked about that talked about that
because let's just say some some folks
haven't heard it talked about this so
because here's the thing some of those
things you are - like for instance you
said this here one time and I actually
this is something that has a lot of
truth behind it how about prozac the
u.s. number-one cause of unnatural death
is suicide now because they give people
suicide mass murder pills now that's
what you call it I want to get people
off their pills that insert says we'll
make you commit suicide and kill people
I want to blame the real culprit suicide
pills mass murder pill is that what
you're insinuating that some of these
large
pharmaceutical companies are producing
products that look like it's a good
thing but it's really hurting you and
killing you I was on Piers Morgan it's
2013 and their Prozac and luvox ads
during the breaks and he's telling me
gun owners are to blame when the shooter
at Sandy Hook was on a prozac drug and
every time every time they're on prozac
they're into the it puts them into a
state that inserts a it can make you
commit mass murder and so that's what
I'm saying is you're pushing this you're
pushing this agenda you're blaming the
Second Amendment and gun ours what every
time it's some weird
thirteen-year-old who's into devil
worship who's on a prozac drug who's
into shoot-'em-up games and so I'm
saying these drugs say they can cause
mass murder psychotic breaks they do
there are a looseness in class and so I
was saying don't blame the Second
Amendment and what somebody else does
who has a car or a baseball bat or a gun
yeah blame that and boy they were they
were at me on the whole hour they said
they cut that thing right then because
they literally had prozac style drug ads
on during the breaks so let me flip that
on you do you believe in background
checks with guns I believe in the Second
Amendment and I think criminals are any
guns regardless but I do think with
mental health other issues as long as
it's become drug county and I think a
background check is probably good so a
background check that does maybe if
you're on prescription right now you're
taking Prozac whatever it is some of the
medication list that we have that is
either for bipolar or whatever you know
things that we just talked about those
folks can't get a gun you're ok with
that
here's the thing 30% of women are on
those drugs about 15% of men and a lot
of people don't act like maniacs when
they're on it but I say this before you
restrict my right people that are on
those drugs when the insert says it can
make it be a killer they should be
looked at I think if somebody has been
diagnosed as psychotic and it's on those
drugs there should be a database and you
shouldn't be able to have a fire okay
fine I mean that's that's we got to a
pointer this is good what every time
my shooting they're like have 10
psychiatrists they're on all these drugs
and then they have a gun illegal and
they'll kill people but you see what you
said right there makes sense so somebody
can go out there and say I disagree Alex
it's okay
or do you concede that's actually not a
bad point you make a point Dirk great I
love this this is so refreshing
no one ever accuses me to my face they
just lie about what I said or edited I
want to be accused I'm proud of what
I've done I'm not perfect I've made big
mistakes there's tons of stuff I wish I
were done better I wasn't here the
moment but I stand by what I've done
overall but I stand by what I've
actually done not what media claims I've
done so you're like hey you're okay
doing this interview
yeah I'm interrogating you I love it
this is what I appreciate is people that
actually face me instead of lying yeah
I'm looking for clarity man I'm looking
for clarity to see your brain like where
is this coming from
I'll try asking this one more time and
I'm curious to know what you're gonna
say initially I asked what caused this
is it self-inflicted you know is it
something that happened is there a blind
spot is there a blind spot like you know
a lot of times in business you know
entrepreneurs business people have blind
spots they're reckless in certain area
they're reckless with gambling they're
reckless with this do you think one of
the blind spots for you is sometimes you
get so excited and animated and your
energy like you your words they come out
so fast because your brains going a
million miles an hour
that's sometimes you catch yourself
overselling something oh definitely
I'll tune in last week okay I was
talking about how Anderson Cooper had
pushed the Arab Spring and I take the
show that Sunday's show I take usually
it's a live show but I take it I mean
I'm in the hot tub of my kids at my
parents house about to go eat dinner and
I hear myself say Tucker Carlson pushed
the CIA invasion of the Arab Spring and
he's a jerk and I'm like that was
Harrison Cooper and I literally call it
Harrison Cooper and I said you probably
won't hear about it but I apologize that
he said oh it's he's I was funny but but
yeah no I totally sometimes like you
hear your rebroadcast you're like god
I'm an idiot
and when you're not all calculating you
get things wrong sometimes so definitely
I get that
I'm Sebastian how was it saying that
were you okay saying that are you okay
well no no but I get things wrong that's
true yeah am i fundamentally trying to
get things wrong though
are you cuz well I'm sitting there and
hear myself say something that's totally
BS I'm like wow you know what TT you
know what double-talk is right you know
with double-talk is like when somebody
had like for instance I used to tease my
dad my dad's you know from Iran and my
mom I would talk to them and I'm just
kind of saying stuff but I also give my
own quick disclaimers and outgoing so I
made a statement but no one knows I made
a double-talk safe I don't think it's
doubled okay so to say sometimes I get
somebody's name doubly wrong not name
no no not name I'm talking
sensationalizing something I'm talking
here's what happened but let me tell you
what else Hillary did let me tell you
what else Barack did let me tell you
what else you know boy your Bush or 9/11
let me tell you what else and then you
take you to hold it like that you say to
seven it's a crisis you take it a lot
undoubtedly I've exaggerated some time
so that's like usually it's like no the
opposite
because if you've got some huge giant
thing that undermines you sometimes do
you think sometimes like you do okay so
I have a seat busy let's go back if I
was just putting on BS why would they be
so worried you're asking why do they
want to ban me so bad yeah I think a
little bit more now that regard is
saying you ever hear the same when they
sack can do 99% things right and 1%
wrong but they remember to 1% they do
but what I'm saying is they're not
trying to ban me because I'm full of
horse manure
they're trying to ban me because I've
got their numbers do you think you're
the only person in the world that has
their number come on Ellis okay I'm
gonna ask you why are they obsessed with
banning me look at the cameras tell them
why does not annoy me
I just told you I'm I've said in
multiple times you you think you'll does
I get a little little too wound up
they're not scared of that they love
that tell me why they're trying to ban
me tell you why why they're trying to
ban you yeah if it's just like they
don't care if somebody's out of turn
they don't care if somebody's gone too
far they're trying to ban me because I'm
exposing their program because you think
you're the only person that knows this
stuff nope I'm trying to make everybody
wake up to it but wait a minute listen
you think you are the only Purcell okay
so if you're not how come other people
have a member so why are they because
they're setting the precedent with me
but you're on the internet if I'm gonna
ban somebody I'm gonna ban it in a
complete different way why would I come
after you what why would I come after
you listen I understand you're your your
top at what you do I fully get it
but even you today you could say
something like the Reuben report you
could Jordan Peterson you know the Ben
Shapiro some of those guys are they they
want to set the President to pairing
them I think they take me because they
think they can take me out of context
because they see me as weak to ban me
that's the big truth they see you as
weak to ban you they think they can take
me out of context and get everybody to
agree to ban me and once that first
domino falls everybody falls that's
total answer okay you're asking the
questions you're a smart guy why are
they trying to ban me that boom I think
you're overselling I think you're
sensationalizing I say why band size
ever selling that doesn't because that's
the whole part about conspiracy let's
just say something happened you're
putting the fear in people's minds and
hearts that's not cool to do so if you
sit there like answer my question I what
is it that gets the whole power
structure and twenty-plus tech companies
lined up to ban me in one day you know
that's never happened let me give you so
no no no it's not just like oh it's over
selling what is it I did that scares the
living hell out of them what is it what
is it you did that's scares the hell out
of them no no they no one's ever had
this happen okay what it's not just oh
right I was you know
okay talk about talk about the child
pedophilia okay hamish know how many
people have talked about that spotlight
they made a movie about and liberals
played in a movie so it's not like
they're saying it's a conservative a
Republican think they went after the
shows tell me what is it I want to know
you're smart guy tell me with you
exactly what I said here's the story
this is what the story is okay you add
stacks on top of the stacks on top of
the stuff on top of the stuff and you
over sensational lives and you're
getting me to say wait a minute this
conspiracy got a little deeper and
you're getting people to take action on
it for instance the whole thing with the
pizza gate
okay so you say this perfect then all of
a sudden I'm like full let's just say
I'm a true believer in the Alex Jones
and what he says because a lot of people
are you got a big following and suddenly
you say if this did somebody goes and
shoots outside let's talk about that
let's talk about it let's talk about it
we have the WikiLeaks in New York kids
in hot tubs sex all devil-worship
Aleister Crowley stuff it's in there
okay and we've got like it coming out
with Weiner all of it and then suddenly
New York Times Washington Post sin and
say no pizza game which was FBI code
words where they use pizza Italian food
names for pedophilia is this place we go
look it isn't there the media then
focuses on us reporting on other reports
to say we're saying that that's
happening here as a way to demonize us
and black out all the other coverage of
what's going on the other subject that's
what's going on with pizza gate okay you
did it again no I told you Alice I'm I
told you okay that's what happened we
didn't progenitor
why didn't create the pizza gate story
mainstream media grew up by taking that
approach okay so you lost credibility
the moment you go that approach so let
me explain to what I mean by this when I
see okay so go back to it Pizza Gate MX
IBM Bohemian Grove this is where they go
you know this story everybody's read
this story the people that follow this
stuff know that that kind of stuff
happens I get it yes no one's saying no
but because you overly sensationalize
you make me take the credibility out of
what's coming out of your mouth and so
for me I'm sitting there let's just say
whoever on I'm suck I'm I'm Jack Dorsey
how many of these guys I'm sitting I'm
getting heat which I'm getting all the
time you know they're getting heat all
the time to want to ban Trump so he
can't do it because Trump ops was a
stock go up so and then there is the
shooting what if you wouldn't have gone
that route what if it was just purely
educational what it was just I'm gonna
go there's no doubt there's no doubt
when I see the New York Times The
Washington Post CNN shame the conspiracy
theorists say there's a sex club in this
place in DC and then we cover it and
they say
I did it you better believe now I don't
cover that is it fair to see that you
understand that I never covered that
pizza place until the Washington Post
and there were times to see it ended and
then 4chan which is a bunch of
operatives supplied all the BS
and then my reporters covered it you
understand we didn't create that story
but you have been talking about parts of
that snow the media are you talking
people 63 what people on the street walk
up and they go f you pizza gate and I'm
like I didn't create that story like
they go they walk up they go but I had a
lady walk up two days ago when I was the
grocery store I was buying cherries and
cheese and like food hamburger meat
hello he walks over she goes f you stop
harassing the Sandy Hook families I
looked at her I said lady I questioned
that five years ago what other people
did and she goes f you Russian that's
what the media told me let's stay on
this topic
listen no they go back to graduate of
Sandy Hook in this interview so I don't
to go back to San Diego but that's all
they talk about but I don't want to talk
about that I want to say very good let's
start talking about it I believe it
happened and I'm sorry with the family
goddammit staying this topic let's say
pizza gate let's stay focus on this
topic here okay you said I wasn't the
one that first brought that out okay
because you said once I'm on megyn kelly
megyn kelly said what do you get your
information from you said we go online
we get to gather data from different
news she edited the living hell I'm sure
he did that's what they don't I'm sure
she did CNF I said I believe Sandy Hook
happened you watch the show it's my
head's John around you notice my head's
jumping around I like your show there's
not a bunch of edits you understand I
told her a year and a half ago in Austin
Texas in the hill country that I believe
it happened I'm sorry for the family and
by the time she and it sounds like I
said that's not fair man I said here it
happened just like I told her imagine
how that feels
that's why I did this interviews you
don't edit stuff I didn't say that I've
got to record it I'm gonna use it in
court
imagine learn from
we going Jones says nobody done and I
play what she said on video I got a tape
and then it tape people see it they're
gonna see it have you put it out yet
I put part of it out yeah the lawyers
won't put it all out but the point is is
how'd you know how about WMDs I didn't
do all the stuff I people question
things and they looked at my whole
life's work and said let's point at this
and let's go after it for that
let's stamp it's a game fair let's go up
it's again I'm gonna remind you what you
just said to me about two minutes ago
you said I didn't bring up pizza gate
other people did and then I started
talking about it right fine that's kind
of like you saying I didn't invent guns
John Doe did I just used it so you took
that story that they started talking
about and then you sensationalized it
and a guy went out there and shot the
place so the part when you're asked you
know the media said some out-of-work
actor looked into them that no even
proved shot the place did that it's like
a wedding vice versa moment whatever it
is whatever it is so the concern no no
no CNN and MSNBC there were times they
kicked it off okay I get that fine
but the guy was inspired after a
sensational okay so everything I ask
everything I processed am I supposed to
do no Alex we have 50,000 emails and
they're talking about Anton LaVey and
they're talking about Alistair Crowley
and how kids are going to be in hot tubs
and other air drinks you're changing the
subject no it's in the goddamn air with
you but they changed the subject from
the fifty thousand emails about drinking
sperm to this place in DC maybe change
the subject okay say they did say they
did yeah they change the subject
fine if I'm running a country Alex say
I'm running a country okay see I'm a
president of a country and I got two
terms okay i as the leader of the nation
have to sit there and make sure the
decisions that are being made are going
in the right direction
and I want to make sure conspiracy
theories if they're being told they're
being held accountable and my biggest
concern as somebody that runs the
country is going to be hey
I don't want somebody that's taking a
story and sensationalizing and making it
more so what's the benefit of that well
I got to make sure I allow both sides of
the media to have platform now if I'm a
dictator I can only get one sighs all
right so they've shut me down but you
but no I mean I'm being shut down sure
yeah here's a couple things educational
system how do you feel about it you're a
college dropout yourself I believe you
went to a community college or something
like that and you dropped on me too I
went to a community I didn't go to a
state or private I dropped that what is
your thoughts on a current educational
system I think it's a total scam like
Rush Limbaugh used to say I went to
college I could have got into UT and I
already had a couple jobs I was making
like more than the professor's worth I
was making $100,000 a year and there the
professors were making like $40,000 a
year it was all this anti-american crap
so I was in sales and a bunch of other
stuff when I was like 19 years old and
so I just thought it was more of an
indoctrination thing so I went to
Community College for two years and
that's why I got of you know modern
education which I think isn't actually
getting ready for the real world I think
it's politically kind of just
indoctrinating ish that's where I stand
on modern education I think it's case is
great overall if it's based on what's
really going on like engineering or
things like that but I think general
degrees now are joke
so stem you need school anything outside
of stem you don't necessarily need to go
to schools that kind of what you're
saying yeah I mean people need to you
know know engineering that you know
they're gonna probably a lawyer go to
school but mainly it's the thing about
getting in big debt mainly the concern
is that they're gonna get into big debt
do you have a strong opinion on how you
would improve it because I'm curious
I actually am curious to know if there
is one two three things you say here's
what we could do with the educational
system to improve it or it's an on top
and non-issue
the educational system is about
political indoctrination so I would fix
it by making it based on real up-to-date
real world application for engineering
for culture for science for jobs not
about being politically indoctrinated so
they are patiently political cults now
and education
for most applications is worthless
today in 2018 okay interesting David
Brock okay you know what David Brock is
you know how time called them possibly
the most influential Democrat in the
world possibly outside of obviously the
people behind closed doors that he's got
a lot of influence what do you think
about him and the level of influence
that he has I mean David Bronk is
basically George Soros is toilet
so whatever George Soros craps out on us
is into David Brock so their drug is
just a soulless globalist that takes
hundreds of millions of dollars to
attack the First Amendment infiltrate
many organizations engage in all sorts
of horrible activities I mean David
Brock is just a absolutely treacherous
individual this is country and he's
George Soros his toilet so who do you
more concern math is who like his mouth
is the toilet bowl so who are you more
concerned about Soros or him oh I would
I mean Brock is just a toilet bowl I
mean I'm more worried about the bloated
belly of Soros and all that poison of
what he does okay thoughts on deep space
state versus Illuminati any thoughts
anything that's new I mean deep state is
just the bureaucracy and the shadow
government is the CEO g cotton the
government people they come in
Illuminati that's just an outmoded name
for secret societies so I don't think
the two actually combined together but
you got a lot of corporate special
interests and a lot of glad handers to
get in positions of power and don't
actually think about prosperity or real
business deals
they just think about overall power and
so I think that's the confluence of the
deep state and the shadow government as
for Illuminati that's just some fanciful
term from France two hundred seven years
ago so it's not what people make it out
to be if you want to be technical in
21st century parlance the Illuminati
means the illuminated or the Renaissance
but the people pushing the modern limit
Isis
some are one in control so no one who's
actually seriously trying to build a
civilization calls themselves the
Illuminati no one's that no one really
that's trying to build a civilization
calls himself silly Illuminati even dual
um Illuminati is a good word you
illuminate it that's what you're saying
yeah it just means illuminated so you
could technically say like Trump's the
head of the Illuminati like are they
running the world
no no Illuminati and Latin means
eliminate okay and so you can say I'm
they have the Illuminati Trump said
Illuminati there's no group under us and
it becomes this negative term like oh
they're Illuminati
oh there's secret they run things that's
deep stage that shadow government and so
the two things one is a term in Latin
for different revolutionary groups the
other is real names of real stratas of
governmental systems with Thumba 9/11
since today is 9/11 at what point did
you come out when you came out and you
talked about what you thought was taking
place with 9/11 who was really behind a
9/11 would what you've studied over the
years and what you've spoken about I
don't know who's behind it I got up at
6:00 a.m. like I used to okay
I still do and at like eight o clock in
the morning
oh my god a plane crashed in oh my god
it's a terror attack and I went on the
air because I was on the syndicated
network and I covered it and then I was
during breaks listening local news
Washington news and they're like yeah
bombs in the buildings and then I want
to get a pizza like four o'clock
and they're saying on CBS radio bombs in
building seven they're gonna blow it out
for everybody's safety so I go on air
and I say I just heard CBS Radio News
back when I still had it 18 years ago or
seven years ago and I go they just said
that Salomon Brothers building was blown
off by bombs and I got international
newspaper for it and it wasn't for five
years that they uploaded the CBS the Fox
the CNN full day and it was CNN BBC CBS
all saying
sunlen brother's building BBC bombs have
been placed we take it down to not
damage local bail
what's the designation and everybody was
like whoa generals said that cuz I made
a big deal out of it I don't know who
blew it up I don't know I went a mile to
get a pizza at like four o'clock I'm
getting the pizza and I'm in the car
eating and driving home and they're
saying Salomon Brothers building
building seven controlled demolition so
won't damage local buildings and I go on
here and I go they're blowing up
building seven and I'm attacked in
papers the next day and then now I've
got BBC on three channels ABC CBS all
saying and they did and they go we'll
conspiracy theory what happened I don't
know
they said they blew it up I heard it and
now we have tapes and they go well they
go to the firefighters blow it up no
they or the police didn't know I don't
know what happened but I can sit there
and play you CBS ABC CNN - BBC channels
saying they're gonna blow up building
seven in a controlled demolition to save
local buildings and they call me a
conspiracy theorist
I was shoving cheese and pepperoni pizza
in my mouth listening to it and the
goddamn tape is public and then I'm the
bad guy I just heard them say on CBS
radio they're going to blow up building
seven and for five years it was in
public and they suddenly released it all
online and anybody can go type in line
police say they're blowing up building
seven or building seven in control today
you will hear and see the newscast what
happened I don't know I'm asking you
what happened
till today with all the research you've
done you don't know you you don't have
any you know you you have some family
that was in a military that was in a
government that they worked in the
government so you've spoken to other CIA
agents the age and some other people
that are on the inside from your
perspective you don't have any strong
evidence that it was either somebody
involved on the inside or not on the
inside here's the best thing we know
Dick Cheney wrote rebuilding America's
defenses the year before
P knack document and it says we want a
new Pearl Harbor that kills at least
3,000 people it says this and we want to
use bio weapons to kill the Muslims and
back then I was more of a liberal I
still want to call the Muslims and I'm
like holy hell and only the awesome
burger Statesman picked it up but that
was in the hunter State he Dick Cheney
says we got ray specific weapons and the
problem is it'll kill 22 percent of
whites and like 70 percent of blacks
because Arabs are a mix of the two but
we should be ready to release it and I'm
like reading this in the peano documents
right after 9/11 happen I had right at
for it happen and they're talking about
killing everybody and I talked about
world government and I mean these are
public stuff you're gonna read this and
I'm reading this and they go we need a
Pearl Harbor we 3,000 dead to invade the
Middle East I don't know man
they're writing documents saying do this
attack and then they're there stand
downs at NORAD I don't know all I said
was they released NORAD footage at NORAD
audio like six months after we were like
god we've never seen a drill like this
somebody took control of our screens and
we've got eight nines wherever they
calmly they've got Sidewinders being
fired into planes and flight 93 and I
talked to the general that was in charge
of and he died two days after and then I
talked to the guy that was that
emergency management deputy head and
they killed him like a week after and
I'm just like whoa I'm interviewing
generals and captains and deputy heads
of Emergency Management and they're all
dying in the week's interview like in
the newspaper they're dead and you asked
while I'm alive I don't know man
that's what I'm telling you is nobody's
got a pay grade this high I don't know
man I don't know all I know is is that
nobody's got a pay grade this height to
know exactly what happened I don't I
don't know what happened all I know is
we have footage a police say get
they're gonna blow it up and I talked to
the cops that were there on the tape and
they go yeah it was it was the it was
the Red Cross and they say we're gonna
blow up building seven get back we're
gonna blow up building six and they have
a countdown on tape that it blows up I
mean these are this is on TV and so
people then go well who did it Jones
tell us I don't know there's people on
tape doing countdowns for buildings
being blown up I don't know
did you watch Fahrenheit 9/11 by you
Michael Moore what was the initial
reaction with it did it cause any other
conspiracies or any questions did you
second-guess anything did you question
anything yourself I mean I knew
everything in the film like they're
flying Saudi Arabians out the day after
9/11 it was kinda like bush knew it
happened it was kind of a whitewash
would already know I mean so it didn't
change any party of opinion at all there
were all these FBI agents saying they
were ordered to stand down and so I was
already knew all that like Fahrenheit
9/11 came out like a year later or like
2003 two or three years later rubble the
election people blame you for conspiracy
and they say you have all these
different conspiracies which they all
right you have some things that you talk
about right okay well you looked it up
they would call a conspiracy that I said
a film came out but they just do that
some of this stuff dirac yours some of
this stuff they overly do you make it
easy sometimes for these people to take
shots at you some people also on the
flip side say listen Alex could have
contacts on the inside with the CIA and
DEA that he knows people that are
feeding him stuff etc etc is there
anybody you know that on the inside
that's connecting you and telling you
stuff because if that is true you would
have more information on 9/11 because if
the stuff you were talking when you got
5 billion views then wouldn't somebody
from the inside who is opposing like
right now I did send there's somebody on
the inside that's working with Trump
that opposes him somebody would contact
and say like Alex here's some
information I'm gonna pass down to you
here's the deal wouldn't date if you
went and bought groceries five years ago
are you worried about the groceries you
about five years ago no we're trying to
get the economy going we're trying to
in the country we're trying to stop war
I don't talk to people about what
happened you know 18 years ago
today's 9/11 i brought it up because
it's 9/11 no no I'm not saying you're
wrong no no no we're not trying to fight
old fights we're not trying to open all
wounds where I'm trying to hurt
globalist we just want them to get out
of the way for American success I mean
do I talk to people you know in
corporations and media and and like Oh
some sexiness of government agencies
yeah yeah but it's not like they're just
American patriots like I am so I'm not
like sitting there talking about what
happened 17 years ago with people we're
trying to like how do we boost the stock
market how do we fix the country how do
we make Americans come together I mean
I've been in these meetings you want
talk about CIA generals everything it's
like we need to racially bring people
together we need to like try to find out
how to not be war with Islam and try to
get radicalism out of the way we need to
bring everybody together we need to like
be peaceful and how do we make the world
a better place it's it's literally with
Trump how do we make a better future it
is not the leftist saying race war
religious war it's the opposite with
Trump it is we want unification we want
a free market system we want justice and
your mission is to empower people and
have them believe they're powerful and
whether they're a Christian or a Muslim
or agnostic or gay or straight to unify
people around a human victory for the
planet that's what Trump's doing that's
why they're pissed so the the meetings
with the CIA and the Pentagon and the
generals and that's what's happening
there is a real group that realizes
humanities is so much trouble with AI
and so much trouble with all the
globalism and everything and what was
happening is so crazy this anti-human
mania that was being run by a big tech
that's still in power that there are
people going we want to be good we want
to be close to God let's get close to
God what do we do to be good people and
everybody's like we want to be good I
mean while big texts like humans are
over the human things over a icier
silicon kill everybody and we're just
like well what do we do I mean it's like
literally do we laughter these people
the people that aren't sellouts that f
souls are like
literally not going what do we do there
looking at all the heads of tech right
now they're looking at and they're just
like Jesus these people aren't pro human
what are we going to do this it's not
like we don't care about media we don't
care about any of this stuff we're
literally trying to chart a human future
okay you just did to me what politician
is doing they they went away from the
question so just to finish off 9/11 okay
to finish off the top question I don't
know what has sold of course the
official story of 9/11 it's worse yet I
gave you a definitive decisive answer so
your your answer the last question I ask
you is CIA DEA nobody else gave you any
information on the inside you knew for
months before there's nothing that you
know about it was just you know when you
said I think so I watch them on TV
al-qaeda's gonna attack then lot give
your rights up winning it was obvious
was gonna ever
it was obvious what was gonna happen
well you don't know who did it you you
have no idea you know it was obvious
that the deep state was gonna stage a
terror attack okay and they did it
working with radical Islam but like like
who did it or influence you don't have
an opinion on that on who influenced it
on the inside I mean III think elements
of the US government elements the
Israeli government elements of other
governments did it but I thought it was
like just attacked Muslims I was against
that but it wasn't that it was to like
take over the existing order launched a
huge war destabilize the Middle East and
then collapsed that into Europe it was
ten times more evil that even imagine
hmm so I was against it I thought was
just an anti-muslim thing and the way to
do it wasn't that it was to go in and
destabilize the Middle East to put the
bad guys in charge did you get criticism
at that time when you were opposing
George Bush where some of your own
followers who think you are an all tried
Republican were going against some of
the Republicans you know sometimes
people put you as an all fried you're
saying no I had over 120 affiliates
which is a big deal back then we have a
lot more than that now and I lost 70% of
them when I did that because it was the
truth I just I just said I don't know
what's going on with official stories
are not true you lost 70% of them yeah
that's big dollars
believe me I was making a couple million
dollars a year when that happened
bringing money in to fund the new
operation it was but I had to tell the
truth it was it was a hard action
because I heard them say we're going to
blow up building seven on CBS radio yeah
I was there I was there I I didn't know
what all was going on I just knew that
the you know that was happening
I'm half Armenian half Assyrian born and
raised in Iran so you know the Armenian
Genocide the Assyrian genocide I'm in
that community the whole nine April 24
1915 you went right at sink from Young
Turks and you went out at you addressed
it yourself so there was a little bit of
loyalty you got for what you did for
pushing that from your end Armenian
Genocide and Young Turks what would be
what are your thoughts about that I mean
obviously you've spoken about it before
maybe comment on it if you could my view
of the young turks is they're funded by
George Soros who on 60 minutes said he
was a Nazi collaborator and then there's
the weirdness of them being named the
Young Turks which was the militia of the
Turks that killed a million half people
that's like mainline Reuters ap it's all
admitted and then I just noticed they're
always apologists for radical Islam and
they're always saying oh we're not
religious but they are and then I
learned that Soros is funding them and I
learned that these big banks were
funding them and then I learned that
people that brought that up and said why
he called Young Turks they would attack
and they would say the Armenian Genocide
didn't happen when Turkish newspapers
said they were eradicating all the
Christian people in Turkey so that's
what I'm saying they called it a
conspiracy theory and so I've had the
same young turks go after me for year
after year up here and lie about me and
love for my sponsors I had the Young
Turks fool me at the RNC two years ago
they go oh you're in this big area with
all these broadcasts going on inside the
parking garage and they go hey come over
later okay I show up they say ghullam
stage and a glow up of stage and then
they all go get the F out of here you
you came up here and it was all staged I
was like I thought was a joke at first
because they had asked me to come up and
I've been on the show like ten times
before and it was like when they set me
up and did all that I was like well
these people are really bad man because
he was like f you get off the stage he
got here and she was calling me a big
fat ass
and all the stuff and I was like well
you just had to be up on the stage so
it's just they're just cold-blooded
that's all I can say about the young
turks and they were funded by Gulf State
dictators I mean let's look it up
they're funded by really bad people and
I just thank God every day I'm not with
those people so again I was on their
show over the years like more than ten
times I didn't realize who they were and
then people kept saying either died the
Armenian Genocide it looks it out it was
truth I looked at Young Turks and then I
went saw I write about like ten years
and once on movies about it and I was
like Jesus these people are literally
carrying this out and they're denying it
to my face
they're scumbags do you think they also
talk about some theories like conspiracy
theories well if you question somebody
they call it a conspiracy theory I mean
if you question anything or the price of
whatever that means that I categorically
categorically they would be in that
conspiracy theory category as well all I
know is they're force-fed by Google in
YouTube and when I went and confronted
them after they blew me that day at the
RNC they deleted our live videos like
within minutes and then lied about what
we did because we had video they were
saying oh come on over like okay I'll
see you in ten minutes
I walk down here come back they go come
on up and they're spitting on me hitting
me and hitting on you the others video
they spit on me hook it up they spit on
me they spit coca-cola or something I'll
have a drink on me and I'm sitting there
while they're doing this and I'm like
you just and I thought it was a joke and
I don't like kind of dawns on me and
they go Roger stone f you you're not
getting on our show and Roger stones
like 20 feet of waiting us I don't want
to hear show if you watch that footage
it's crazy sometimes you get criticism
because some people say well Alex never
bashes uh Nazis you know a lot of times
they'll say you know he is so nice to
them he is so kind to them he was so
gentle with them what do you have to say
about that
I don't even Nazis were like people we
beat like 70 years ago in World War two
it says it's like a mentally ill joke
about I'm being nice and on see
something nice and Nazis if you go
online and type in Alex Jones Nazis all
he do is attack means
total horse crap so what do you think
about him Nazis yes well they lost World
War 2 in their losers and the KKK had
and groups like that are a joke but it's
like it's saying like what do you think
of child molesters do you think they
still like let me ask you what are you
taught molesters I think they need to be
tracked based on whatever their whatever
they're doing right now and they belong
in prison good I agree so what I think
of Nazis so is that your opinion I'm
asking you I agree
what do you do what I'm asking you what
do you do about Nazis what do you do
about Nazis I'm asking you the question
back imagine like being asked what do
you think of child ravers yeah but
there's a difference with you because
you actually are in this world it's like
somebody asked me about an insurance
policy I sell that maybe I disagree with
you like Stalin not a mess I challenge
you in this Nazis are losers man what
world am i supporting Nazis is like hey
Alex tell me you don't support communist
a mine miles poor communists I'm an
American I love free market I'm not
trying to be friends with Nazis there's
no group that attacks me more than the
Nazis that's why it's a bizarre
statement to ask about Nazis because the
average Nazi is a southern poverty law
center ADL operative good catch man
seriously it's like asking me what do
you make of these guys that stole
pumpkins last week out of this yellow
thing on i-45
am i right up it sometimes brought up
with you no one ever thought up exactly
yeah it's old man
the Nazis really yeah but it also gets
old on the flip side when every time
something happens you say you know this
Hitler did this back in the days and
America is doing the same thing so I'm
asking a question because sometimes some
part give me the example you say I said
that America is like Hitler give me give
me example are so the first five minutes
you said that first five minutes of
today said what I say
you want me to replayed for you
now it's tens of thousands of articles a
month everywhere lying about me never
showing what I supposedly said just
claiming I said something and I said
this is clearly just like the Nazis did
so I'm Pro Hitler but I'm criticizing
Nazi Germany no you're not prohibit or
were you criticizing them you bring that
old oh no III definitely agree I don't
think Jeremy's elves medieval the world
but I think it did a lot of bad stuff
and 22 million Germans diverse five
minutes you brought it up okay well no I
brought up Germany was bad number well
you're saying what America is doing is
what there's no so what I but I think I
rest my case I know so Amaya Nazi no I
said it's wrong to be a Nazi I rest my
case
so you don't support what they stand for
National Socialism and like killing
people that aren't German hell yeah I
disagree with that
okay simple why let me ask you this yeah
d crybosdaisy do who just tell me you're
not for child molesters I'm not tell me
you're not Nazi I'm not good
tell me you're not no okay hey remember
I'm not see how dumb it is though
it's dumb oh no that way when have I
this is the craziness of leftist busy
diversity I challenge you to find
anywhere that I support loser Nazis
Jesus Christ you know how much they hate
me this is a good thing this is not a
bad thing but they're idiots do you know
as a Nazi websites hate me more than
Netanyahu and then not in Yahoo they
claim I work for a Netanyahu they
everywhere the fake cube movement says
I'm this Mossad agent all this [ __ ]
I've never even been to Israel so
imagine like from one end
I'm mrs. Railly agent and then the other
end I'm Miss nonsan I don't think you've
ever done to Israel Israeli a story and
been stronger that you've always just
been I've never been there before you're
not they've done some bad things but
they're you know they've done a lot of
good things yeah it's like any country
yeah sure it's like America is like do
you like America or do you like Israel
you've had different different agencies
they had different presidents I agree is
the point so why don't we talk about him
all day I'm sick of it this is a
platform we have it's opened
now I'm gonna dispel them yeah for you
to address everything that's being
accused of you I'm assuming this is
going to be viewed by many people around
the world who have no no I get it
they're right they call every
conservative laughing yeah you they
called Trump any Semitic when he's
pro-israel I sure yeah so there you go
here's another one for you you brought
up a couple things initially and you
said you know the media is pretty much
done what they've done to me and I said
if you know as much as you know why
haven't they killed you okay and then
you give your answer so what is more
powerful in a time like this is it
better off to kill the brand and the
influence or is it actually to go to the
other way around and which which one's
gonna hurt you more and put more fear in
the other people that are wanting to
speak on the topics that you're talking
about but see I'm not thinking about
geopolitical or Machiavelli I'm just
doing what I think's right that's the
real pure path is that I'm not thinking
about what's gonna happen or looking at
the angles I'm just trying to tell the
truth promote America promote freedom
and do what has to be done that makes
sense it's a safe answer but okay
I don't know it's not a safe answer
ladies I mean it's a where's the
Machiavelli I believe in free market I
believe in America I'm a Christian I
believe the Second Amendment I believe
in Trump and he's delivered or when he
say yeah and so what am I supposed to do
[ __ ] Karen like politically try to
tinker toy with every level of this I
mean ask your question again you're
saying it's a safe answer no that's not
the same answer that's why they hate me
because I'm a purist I'm actually doing
what I think's right ask question again
what's more powerful getting rid of
somebody or shutting them down with the
voice on what to say and on social media
platforms what's more powerful is
demonizing someone and assassinating
their character in public before you
kill them and you think that's what's
happening with you oh yeah I had Muller
try to set me up last week it's been bad
but that's okay because this is I'm
playing at the big-boy level it's not
about it seriously it's not about me
making it but you said I'm playing at
the big-boy level if you're gonna play
at the big-boy that with the big-boy
level those Makaveli know do you think
Jesus plated the Mac available I don't I
don't know if I'm saying Jesus is big
boy
I'm not talking about we're level I'm
saying there's a level above that just
being straight up so you think that's
the level you plant in light mileage
it's the next level the next level isn't
yourself I could not enlighten the level
is what you're saying I really want
prosperity in the future okay and I'm
against globalism and I want to
sexualize children and I am next level
yes fair enough
okay you've asked me why they fear me
the answer is right there because I
can't be bought I'm not another control
I love God you can't be bought well you
wouldn't mean you can't be bought cannot
be bought what does that mean you can be
bought though there is no price already
sold your sell products on a weekly
basis though those no way that's to fund
me but I would sell poison to people to
get ahead I sell things and t-shirts and
books to fund myself but that's the
people buying because they believe what
I'm doing I'm not compromising go a
little deeper with this what do you mean
I'm not compromising you're selling
you're making money you can't be bought
what can't be bought but selling things
is only fuel to carry out my operation
okay selling things is to fuel to carry
out my operations but you can't be
bought yeah like the heart it needs
money is not the tip of my pyramid doing
good for Humanity and winning is where I
want to go and so I'll sell t-shirts
books videos water filtration air
filtration and enforce order calm to
fund myself but my god is not that money
you certainly understand that sure okay
here's lightning round you ready I'm
gonna give you a word a name and you
tell me the first thing that comes to
your mind okay or a little bit longer
than the first thing that comes to my
let's see what you're gonna say your
brain is a fast brain see let's see what
you're gonna say first one Edward
Snowden Patriot really Ted Cruz Patriot
back to back Julian Assange Patriot
Bernie Sanders vampire Putin nationalist
beta beta was the one that's going
against a minimum mental [ __ ]
Bill Gates eugenicist Elon Musk a scared
man really LeBron James
[ __ ] colin kaepernick [ __ ] Steve
Bannon traitor
David Brock vampire Hillary Clinton
vampire Barack Obama vampire Bush
vampire Trump that's low did you see
next level next level
Moses Trump is Moses oh yeah elaborate
what do you mean by Trump as Moses he's
the real friggin deal my God knows it's
all clear he's he's Pro him and he wants
progress he is one of just he's our had
everything and he's he's dial down to
the real deal I guess they call that
deliver trumps to deliver if we take it
we've already seen it I've already seen
everything suppressing us and then as
soon as he comes in grass and flowers
and powers everything's waiting right
now Alex assume anybody there that the
decision-makers watching this I'll give
you two final thoughts what are you
thinking about right now you have the
platform you have the audience what
would you like to say I'd say the
decision-makers are already watching
I think the decision-makers already know
the choice they're just afraid to stand
up to this anti human thing and they're
afraid that the public isn't willing to
make the right decisions but that's what
leadership is about and so people have
to decide which side they're on
I mean this is like a big spacewalk they
say those astronauts walk out and the
space station or from the space shuttle
it's like you're looking down the earth
ten thousand miles look I'm infinity and
it's like they said it doesn't like it
and that that's it you have to believe
in humanity and if you just do that
everything else follows so that's it
then that's why they don't like me you
guys had question over and over again is
because I don't fear them I've already
been around the bed
I've already seen where it goes and
that's scary
because they've not been that but there
will be there soon enough they're gonna
meet their maker
and they're gonna face god alright I
with pure consciousness and they're
gonna have to decide who they serve so
today you get a chance to decide for
yourself from everything you heard he
was pushed we addressed every single
topic that we can think about and he was
open he gave his thoughts he gave his
opinions I appreciate you coming out it
was great I loved being challenged I'm
with you this was good and I'd like to
hear your thoughts what do you think
about today's conversations what are you
thinking about it the agree do you
disagree were you at with the whole
situation that's taking place should he
be back allowed back on social media so
should Facebook YouTube everybody so you
should come back on or no a guy like
this shouldn't be on YouTube what do you
think I want to hear from you
comment below Alex thank you for taking
time to come on value Tim it truly thank
you for making the time to come on by
the beds hey I'm proud to be bad about
these people you're proud to be banned
by these Nazi Zombies why we're only on
their phones it's yeah it's a this is a
real honor if you'll keep thinking I'm
like hurt by being ostracized from hell
it's a good deal man the Satan cast me
out that's the reverse of how supposed
to war I mean I'm seriously hard that's
Satan cast me out thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye Satan cast
alex jones outlets everything